so Eric we're here at collector mania
that's your first time here this year
isn't it how you finding it oh I'm
having a great time it's a little cold
but everybody's so nice and so it's been
fun meeting everybody people who really
liked the show and liked my character
and so you know it's all love which is
which is wonderful and all the people
who all the organizers and the staff are
very nice as well so it's been very
pleasant
now you mentioned the fans there of
course there's a lot of fans there's
still a lot of fans of bones what kind
of stuff they've been asking you today
when are you coming back everyone's know
what I'm coming back and what's it like
to work with the cast which are all
wonderful people and what have you been
telling them I don't know if I'll ever
come back it's possible it's always
possible I know they've talked about it
so you ever know and like I said when
they asked me about what's it like to
work with the actors they were all
wonderful people I still stay in touch
with don't you think it was about bones
it is about bones that makes it so
popular it was a huge success isn't it
well I know people like crime-solving
shows but this is interesting because of
the way they saw the crimes by studying
the skeletal remains and although they
can learn from doing that but I think
what else attracts people to it is the
humor there's a real light sense of
humor and they really develop the
characters very well I think people
really become connected and close to the
characters and that's why they want to
keep watching tracted you to make bones
in your character in particular well I
moved to LA eight years ago and I wanted
to do a television show and I got bones
actually pretty quickly and I was really
hoping of all the shows I was
auditioning for that I get that one I
liked the idea of being in a crime
solving show being an hour-long drama
and it was a fun character so it was
everything that I wanted to do and I
felt very fortunate when they cast me
what was the best thing about being on
the show the best thing about being on
the show getting to work getting to act
every day came to go to work and do
scene after scene after scene I love
acting I'll always be an actor so any
chance I get to act I'm just very happy
now if you did come back into the show
and we'd love you to obviously what
would you like to be doing what your
ideal storyline
well I know that people are telling me
about the serial killer now named pelant
and they're all saying i exac can catch
pelant I could catch blood so if they
think Zack can do it maybe I could do it
what do you even see since we saw you
last in bones I wasn't you last saw me
on bones does cap Oratia I've been doing
around the country in LA and New York
and DC now I'm gonna do it from my
hometown in Oregon in July so I'm very
excited about that gosh what else have I
been up to been auditioning for you know
shows to try to find my next you know my
next project I did a movie last summer
called lady peacock tell us a little bit
about lady peacock lady peacock is about
a guy two guys [ __ ] feet fighting over
the same guy and one's a drag queen and
the other one realizes to catch the the
guys attention that he has to be in the
drag contest to try to beat the drag
queen out I play the husband of the
owner of the club and I run a cupcake
shop and I teach cupcake making and tell
us a little bit about that cabaret show
as well I love to hear about it yeah it
was a show that I'd done really since
like 2000 that I've done in New York and
all over the place right right after I
left bones I did it in LA and Washington
DC and then this last year last year I
did a whole new selection of songs Barry
Manilow and Tracey Ullman and some
Broadway stuff and we'll young
and Peter Paul and Mary lots of fun
songs and I did that in New York and now
I'm putting that show on again to get to
get in an Oregon and I have a nice in
the past you only do it with piano now I
have very good pianist still but I have
a drummer and a bass player world-class
musicians and it's really fun singing
with them and the bassist just so good I
do this song called all the love I have
which is from Angela Webb errs the
beautiful game and there's a little
break in it and the bass player does
this little musical break where he plays
like the melody of the song and it's
just so gorgeous I love it the first
time I rehearsed with the band and he
played that I turned around I was like
that is so beautiful so I'm glad I was
like I have to fly all three of those
musicians and put them up and pay them
to come to Oregon with me because
they're all so wonderful yeah it's gonna
be great playing your hometown as well
I'm guessing yeah Springfield Oregon if
anybody's on the west coast or near
Oregon I'd recommend you come it's at
the Wildish Theatre in Springfield
Oregon wildest theatre com-pub when's it
gonna be on July 13th yeah I just came
back to bones briefly oh you're kind of
favorite moments and scenes that you
played over the years or maybe your
favorite memories when you were off set
as well off screen with friends in the
show well my favorite episode was the
first year's Christmas episode the man
in the fallout shelter where we were all
trapped in the lab I had a lot of fun
with that that was we really got to all
work together more often than in the
other episodes because it was just us
and maybe my favorite scene ever though
was I think it was second season where I
punched Hodgins that was fun
that was a really really fun scene I
enjoyed that so and then off-camera
it's been fun even still hanging out
with the cast even after I've left the
show there's art cg2 I think that's
amazing
TJ thein who plays Hodgins actually went
to Paris with me last fall and we signed
autographs of Paris manga there which
was great other fun things with the cast
and all the Fox parties are fun that
they take us to and where we get to meet
the press and we have a party every year
at the Santa Monica Pier
which is always fun and so it's it was
all a great experience and even looking
at these pictures that people are that
I'm autographing for people I have such
fond memories of all those photo shoots
you